the body
Casey mazzucchi Benatar Keppinger
dominica via Bobby who he wit ur boo
lushness al cielo Gaia Caleb okay Bob
jacket a Pakistani Agriculture Research
Council cake and as Hakeem topic since
did I smile hunky purchases are equal
buncher's amini Celebi panic device
moose Khalifa Janowski Layla take it
when he still he flood khatam hua
tom-toms amino magic nivo production
increase who eva hamper exceeded haga lo
conosce cultivation giora the first
layer break rahila kami yet a mom whose
increase flood giver just ahead
you
Oh
the limitation of space irrigation is
its greatest potential space irrigation
by naturalizer on water that is highly
variable and highly unpredictable and it
tries to convert this highly variable
and destructive flood in something which
is useful and productive spade
irrigation as we are going to present
you can meet the challenges of climate
variability and definitely to have a
bright future and it will be one of the
most important contributors for for
security and water security in the
future